81 million people voted against Donald
Trump sure they did not vote for Joe
Biden we could drive around anywhere in
South Florida and find the Biden voters
none of them like Joe Biden there were
no uh Biden signs on anybody's law and
there's no Biden bumpers tickets Joe
Biden had a anti-trump if Joe Biden had
a rally in Miami nobody is showing up so
my question this is what we were hitting
on earlier that I think everybody out
there if you objectively look at it is
we live in a world where people make up
their mind and I appreciate what you're
saying you have a core set of values but
you're willing to look at the data and
change your mind that's not most people